a priori si l'on vous pose la question
quel est le plus gros producteur de
films au monde la réponse qui vient cet
hollywood etats unis c'est presque ça
puisqu'il s'agit en fait de bollywood
c'est le nom donné ou surnom donné aux
studios de bombay en inde où il se
tourne près de 800 films chaque année
pendant longtemps ces films disons à
l'eau de rose ne sortait pas du pays
aujourd'hui le cinéma indien a envie de
s'exporter vers l'occident vincent
nguyen vinh jacquier reportage
il est des regards qu'on aimerait croisé
seul mais celui de my man les jeunes
autour d'elle lui et de bras s'agitent
en permanence
que voulez vous c'est une star
l'étoile brille à des années lumière de
chez nous un bon bout ça tourne à
bollywood leurs limites de l'inde une
usine à rêves qui fonctionne à plein
régime au rythme étourdissant de plus de
800 films par an ici les acteurs ne
prennent pas la poussière
repéré il ya six ans dans une pub pour
sow d'argent naïma tourne aujourd'hui
son 26e long métrage en annoncé
normalement six ou sept films
moi je fais partie des rares qui se
limite à trois ou quatre mais il ya
maquillant tourner jusqu'à 12 dans la
nuit 00h30 aux dîners on tombera jusqu'à
l'os les moyens de bollywood ne sont pas
ceux du grand frère américain
ce que nous tournons là est un film
nouvelle génération à petit budget il
coûtera 4 à 500 mille euros
il y à d'autres genres de films à
bollywood avec peuvent facilement coûter
dix fois plus mais c'est sans commune
mesure avec vous c'est le premier film
du réalisateur
et s'il a la chance d'avoir une star
c'est que mme heim avait envie de
changement
marre des classiques bollywoodien un peu
kitsch trois heures minimum avec
chansons histoires à l'eau de rose
maintenant on n'applique plus la même
recette tous nos films on peut décider
de faire un film d'action
on fait maintenant mes films 100
chansons qui vise un public plus
internationale et plus seulement l'asie
ton cherche à toucher les spectateurs
qui ne regardaient pas encore notre
cinéma
l'un d'eux bouge et son cinéma avec pour
ce long métrage ni fleurs ni comédie
musicale mais des déboires de cette
jeune à la recherche d'argent pour
tourner un film
j'espère et millions de spectateurs
minimum en elle et après il ya des
marchés importants dans le monde
la malaisie le royaume-uni le canada
sans compter les dvd bollywood à la
conquête du monde
pourquoi pas rien qu'en inde on vend
chaque année 2 milliards et demi de
place et les acteurs ont autant le fan
elle m'a images l'aiment je la donne
elle est jolie elle est bannie du monde
hemayma
la belle a charmé l'inde et ne compte
pas s'arrêter là peut-être bientôt la
france verra-t-elle apparaître sur ses
toiles ce regard que décidément on
aimerait croisé celle